foreign
has two main directions one is molecular
interaction the other one is Max
spectrometry based proteomics
basically every biological pathway
involves molecular reactions that occur
you know either in sequence or together
and it's those Pathways that allow
either normal biological function or
abnormal you know disease our goal of
our group is to actually merge both
directions together because we are
looking at molecular interactions we're
looking at trying to understand diseases
and mass spectrometry basically if you
look as is the fragmentation of peptide
and if you look deeper is actually a
molecular interaction problem because
the amino acid residues are interacting
if we actually have theoretical methods
that can explain this interaction
actually we can solve the original
problem can actually predict the
fragmentation
we have developed a method for
identifying diseases that have different
symptoms so they're seemingly unrelated
but are caused by the same molecular
mechanism identifying such diseases in
is important because such diseases May
respond to the same treatment if we have
an accurate biological model then one
day we will be able to use this
knowledge to identify strategies for
diagnosing treating and preventing
disease
I'm proud that we are able to use
physics very rigorous science to study a
biological objects and that would lead
immediately to results helping to
improve health care and lives of many
people we measure our success by how
well our research result can benefit the
General Public
[Music]
sure